[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
we talk about whatever we want and today
we on Chloe Sharkey polisher was here he
just left median and actor you know I
remember watching you on in a biodome
yeah you're hilarious dude I um - yeah I
don't know we'll see we'll check it out
here first we got a job in here we got
it film it first
are you allowed to swear also yes as
much as you want
I haven't potty mouth sometimes
please lot of the guys that the guys
they just did Bill and Ted's - you know
Bill and Ted yeah today equal yeah so
the same producer of that hit me up
because I guess bill and ted's is owned
by MGM hmm and so it's biodome so
they're like trying to figure it out so
we'll figure it out because I know a lot
of people like biodome yeah yeah you
just did a movie with my buddy Sam
macaroni yes yeah yeah yeah I met you
briefly on the set there oh wow tell
them you don't remember him at all no
yeah he doesn't have to do that geo what
the hell I already I just pointed that
in you know Sam I known for years or
through YouTube oh yeah yeah I tell me
your name again
yeah I don't think myself you were
covered in powder just gotten like like
he's like I remember the C but I don't
remember you yeah Bobby Lee was there
yeah yeah okay that's good Bobby's my
uncle actually yes no that's cool
he's always been here yeah he's he's why
he's always here is he mm-hmm you know
his father died yeah your uncle that's
my glove or anything about a movie I did
see a post about this down and
I didn't know it was like a memorial
poem you read the caption you have to
read the cat I just saw how weird is dad
looking up what's a weird-looking
kindness right there
I know it's [ __ ] my he was just oh my
god dad no bob is telling you my honest
thoughts at that time I don't want to
censor myself I guess yeah cuz you're
not a liar right yeah I mean I
discovered Bobby did you really write
cuz he he told us about yeah the whole
Comedy Store and yeah because in La
Jolla he worked in um he worked at a
place called anything was Brockton Villa
which was a little restaurant in La
Jolla hmm and he worked there and the
first time I saw him was at the Commish
on La Jolla and I was like this guy's
hilarious I mean obviously yeah he was
hilarious and then um and then I took
him under my wing and then I brought him
to see my mom Mitzi shore owner of the
Comedy Store and and and she saw him at
the at the in Vegas and she fell in love
with him and that was it yeah how many
comedy stores are there there's two yeah
there's one in San Diego and then one
the one on it was this before MADtv for
Bobby yeah yeah yeah baby so you're the
reason why he got on MADtv no yeah I
started I did this for a lot of
comedians a lot of people don't know
that a lot of comedians have opened for
me I mean he says this out loud - he
says how much you you've basically gave
him that career you like you put he has
so much respect for your you should you
should yeah you should call him up
that's that's true yeah should be like a
pyramid scam so everything that he makes
and every comic that they may see
visions I get yeah here's a I am I go to
the Korean spa lot you know which one we
spa no not we spy don't like we spot oh
it's to Main Street yeah this is more
like an OG like I don't even [ __ ] to
this day I don't know the name of it
yeah but I'd like literally go I go
probably I'm the only white person that
has like a like a membership all the
Koreans one of those it's real legit so
I see Bobby there all the time yeah so I
get to see us little yellow monster so
he's in the knees in the movie guest
house as well that I just said the movie
should be out next year sometime
some kind of excited about it do you
think you could discover me I'm just
covering you right now when I first
started doing stand-up I do you do
stand-up before not The Comedy Store
couple times not anymore
I did I did perform the Comedy Store a
couple times I don't know if you noticed
anybody like me this is you're just
telling the crowd you know tell them how
you got bumped up all the way to like
5:00 a.m. or whatever like and then
you're just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah so
the Pacino's comedies and gnarly dude
like the real deal yeah the open mic
nights like Tuesday night whatever and
it would be like a guy that would book
me my all you're pretty funny let me
bring you on Thursday on a Friday on a
Saturday and they'll tell me my slide
over here slots like 7:00 p.m. or
whatever and this is me coming from a
YouTube I don't really understand
traditional like stand-up comedy on my
corner I bring all my friends out and
then I don't even call like people from
wildin out or late if Dave Chappelle was
dropped by or whatever and then my slot
just keeps getting bump bump yeah and by
the time I go up I'm like oh it's 11
p.m.
all my friends are already gone drunk a
crowd and I'm like damn this is rough I
can't stick to making videos online so a
drunkard crowd no because we're
belligerent so my Gil say you're trying
to set up a joke and then there are like
in between yeah right in between like
this seven yeah laughs that's don't
laugh yeah these are laughing instead of
like yeah thank something else yeah yeah
sure yeah I'm not a stand-up though I
wouldn't call myself a stand-up like I
did stand-up but I would say I'm an
improviser like that's what I did right
of butter on week and yeah non-stop and
[ __ ] but not stand up mm-hmm that's a
whole other animal it is a big animal do
you still do stand-up on a regular basis
course like every night so you're going
on tour I'm always on tour yeah I'm
always on tour so um excuse me just in
an apple at the Berlin site you know I'd
hate to like speak and I'll send the
[ __ ] Apple burps felt like it came
from your anus right out of your mouth
that's fine
you're like yes what I it's what I do I
always do it
so just in New York and then I was in
Virginia Baltimore and then where am I
going next [ __ ] where the [ __ ] oh I'm
going to Palm Springs when does this
come on by this weekend
yes I'll be in Palm Springs in umbria
and then I'm also doing a one-man show
that I've been working on uh-huh that's
gonna be it will be at lyric Hyperion
next week and then also of the Ice House
next week so I'm always doing [ __ ] how
do you write a one-man show yeah
well it's about my life because everyone
always asked me about growing up at The
Comedy Store and Sam Kennison an MTV so
I figured I'd do it all in a one-man
show so it's basically like it's it's
from my childhood so like right when I
made it so like right so it's like from
when I was born to like the early 90s
and then I end it after like I've made
Inessa and so opens up with like the
heyday and then it goes back to how it
all started so I mean I grew up I grew
up in a very like like like at the time
it's [ __ ] normal
yeah but the older I've gotten I looked
back on it I'm like [ __ ] Richard Pryor
was like in my [ __ ] yeah you know
basement or and like I went to Beverly
Hills High School and I you know
Angelina Jolie was there and like
Nicholas Cage and Lenny Kravitz and and
all this this stuff and there were your
classmates well they were in Beverly
Hills High School
I work different ages yeah so um but um
you know growing up in Beverly Hills
those friends with a lot of like you
know like who else was okay it's smokey
Robinson's kid Gary Roberts it was my
best friend and oh [ __ ] so like yeah all
these like weird things that occurred so
I tell these kind of silly stories about
you know the whole thing yeah so it's
normalized to do is just every day but
at the time it was normal but I'm older
and I look back because I perform a lot
in the Midwest like a lot of my fans are
like you know people in the middle of
the country so like in the last 25 years
that's what I've been doing you know
I've been like touring all over America
so like you know they're just [ __ ]
people that taught like that mofo you
know I mean like that type of [ __ ]
but they're cool you know they're sweet
people have a spirit you know Nemean a
lot of people in like liberal markets
like our market in New York have
stereotypical you know with Donald Trump
they have like a very stereotypical of
what they think of white people and
another country and you know and it's
kind of like they have that same
stereotypical of LA mmm and like it's
kind of like I went to Saudi Arabia
about a month ago
and I did some shows there and I got off
the [ __ ] plane it looked like Isis
physically like everyone's in turbans on
the tail because thank you 47 you see a
dude and I'm like [ __ ] skit yeah but
then once you get to know them they're
just normal people
they're like biodome and [ __ ] right no
but but you're not saying like people
are just people there's good people that
are white there's bad people that are
white there's good people that are black
black people it's like you know it
doesn't really matter you mean there's
good people with southern accents cuz
here you don't hear that a lot all
serial killers are white though common
denominator yeah I didn't want to ask
you though if you could give advice to
your childhood self what would you say
because like growing up in that
environment it's not something a normal
kid growing up in and it kind of just
makes me think about my own sons I have
an 11 year old and he's obviously not
like at your caliber growing up he is
growing up in their same public eye like
you know I did school they'll have like
he'll have older kids be fans of us and
like give them stuff and like just treat
them very differently so I struggle a
lot with like how to help him cope with
that because it's a completely different
type of childhood than when I had yeah I
don't know I don't have I don't have the
answer I really excuse anyway isn't it
different though cuz it you you grew up
with other celebrities kids too
so in that environment like it's almost
normal with everyone yeah it's my arm ah
yeah yeah yeah
we're Isaac's growing up is like he's
not in a Beverly Hills tech school yeah
no it's just a regular suburb you know
you know well my suggestion get off a
[ __ ] YouTube stop being so famous
yeah you named me what do you want my
dog she's thinking of herself I know but
uh yeah it's uh it's interesting I don't
know you know I I don't have an answer
I'm not the you know I'm not dr. Phil so
I'm looking for an answer for my kids
your own childhood like was there
anything you would you wish you would
have known or you could have told you
maybe even something that you wished
your parents did something like to help
I don't know maybe equaliser making
normalize it or something yeah I don't
know I mean I think I'm okay you know I
think I wound up okay and you know I'm
not some sure I'm a drug addict I'm not
like you know some I'm a pretty artist
you know I'm a pretty honest guy and my
life's pretty cool I don't know I've
made some good choices I've made some
bad choices like everyone else did your
mom grew up in Hollywood area - no my
mom is from Wisconsin oh yeah she's my
dad was from Chicago my parents met like
in the 50s oh wow my dad a mom just
passed away like my dad passed away like
it was like about four or five months
ago and my mom passed away like was that
like I don't know two years ago but
they're all they were older and they met
my dad was a comedian he met my mom in
Wisconsin they were he was performing
and then they had sex and got pregnant
and my oldest brother Scott is so I
think 67 well yeah so you know they're
from the Midwest you know my parents are
from the Midwest yeah so and then they
just came out and decided let's open up
a store The Comedy Store it just kind of
happened
yeah because my dad was performing and
then there is this guy named Frank cenis
who owned the car mr. land or the land
where the combustor is and he asked my
dad if he wanted to start a comedy club
and then my dad was like yeah let's do
it and then you know then my mom came up
with the name and it just kind of like
developed in the you know into the 70s
yeah like she started in 1972 so it's
[ __ ] crazy dude
there's a 15 it's gonna be 50 years like
what's one of the craziest things that
they're a lot of [ __ ] Bobby Lee's
[ __ ] penis but he's got he's gotten
his ass beat there yeah is there a
jawline
no cuz uh Ari Shaffir yeah did not Irish
put [ __ ] on his [ __ ] windshield or
some [ __ ] I don't know you know I don't
want to give out all the stories it's
just you know it's a magical place it's
I call it the Emerald City for comedians
you know yeah you know yeah yeah so I
mean I'm one of the owners and you know
I you know I don't know my mom gave it
to me and my brother so what's crazy is
that place just churns out so much
talent like even now like you see the
lineup you just have like you know the
top comics just always there just and
it's so accessible for us we could just
go there any time and just watch em you
know yeah that's crazy yeah I know it's
uh it's you know it's a magical place
and she's setting it up that way so yeah
is there a lot of tribalism there I
remember excuse me like tribalism there
tribalism
yeah we're it's like cuz I did you see B
and I remember we all hated the IO kids
and I all kids hated the UCB kids and
some people did intermingle like yellow
battle with the Laugh Factory yeah I'm
Improv Zuri that signal I don't think so
not anymore
I think like every comic plays all the
clubs at the end of the day it's not how
it was but that's a good question that's
how it was back in the day really yeah
because my mom well my mom would develop
the comedians and she would help them
and then all sudden if you worked
another club she was kind of pissed yeah
because she helped you and you know
amazing and she would be like she'd be
like why the [ __ ] you going there when I
just helped you there so so but then the
comics argument was like yo I got to get
on stage so it's always you know it was
always kind of weird like that that's
like the Joan Rivers Johnny Carson thing
yeah I'm show and he's like [ __ ] you I'm
never talking to you again yeah yeah but
I think now you know it's kind of like a
free-for-all you know you'll watch the
lea on the store and they'll go the
Laugh Factory improv you know mixes it
up you know so I don't know you know
people want to get onstage you know
right yeah but this was like before
social media right because so people
were kind of residents of the
of each comedy club mm-hmm and then they
had their own place to go because people
had a go there to see their comedy yeah
it's different now yeah you know and
plus like you know you talked about the
lines and all that stuff like how
crowded it is it's like you know all
these comics have such big social-media
followings yeah you know II mean so like
back in the day you know if you know Sam
can whoever was performing you couldn't
just do a tweet and all of a sudden
people show up it's like yeah but you
know you just put it on the social it
went boom and then awesome everyone
shows up you don't even mean so it's a
different time you know that's why you
know I enjoyed the the new Leonardo
DiCaprio movie I don't know if you guys
saw that spawn tom hollie yeah it's
[ __ ] dope I mean for me for me I
don't know about you guys you guys are
younger so you weren't really around you
know in the 70s and 80s so you didn't
experience that time here yeah it was
like you know you know if you want to
see a good documentary if you're in the
film
check out kid stays in the picture which
is with Robert Evans Robert Evans used
to run Paramount Pictures and he was
like this really awesome like producer
he produced all these [ __ ] crazy
movies The Godfather and Rosemary's Baby
and all these like [ __ ] crazy movies
like in the 70s that like you know like
even you look at the Oscars back then as
opposed to now like back when I was
growing up the Oscars like to me really
meant something it was a holy [ __ ] Billy
Crystal's hosting and everyone gathered
around and now like people rather be on
their Instagram you know or on YouTube
than watch the next you know the one the
best you know yeah this everyone's just
split and and I'm not saying it's bad
I'm just saying it is what it is two
different times like times they are
a-changin the Bob Dylan song you know I
mean and but I'm just happy for me I was
able to experience you know experience
that those eras you know that era you
know because it's not like that anymore
you know I mean look at poor Kevin Hart
right he wanted to host the Oscars and
they dug into his Twitter crazy
yeah you don't I mean and they found
like oh he said this and that and it's
just like you know the whole I don't
know I mean I don't want to get into it
but the whole thing is just like people
are very sensitive now big time yeah and
it's like we don't allow sensitive ass
[ __ ] no we know that's not allowed
yeah but you know I'm saying it's just
kind of like oh the whole Louie thing's
crazy to me too yeah he can't believe
that he's persona non grata um yeah yeah
we belong to a safe space of [ __ ] up
real industry yeah [ __ ] up Ari yeah
you know we keep we keep [ __ ] alive here
you guys say some [ __ ] up [ __ ] on here
and no one's gonna cancel YouTube
channel big try they canceled his 1.2
million subscribers I can't make videos
anymore basically yeah dude really yeah
I mean look at Roseanne yeah I mean like
[ __ ] dude she's got to be freaking out
because she was like you know she had a
rough time dude in the last 20 30 years
like she was you know in the 80s she was
boom boom boom and then you know she had
her run and then she finally got another
shot and then she at night she did some
she was on ambien or some [ __ ]
and she'd said some some and then they
just pulled it and the drug company made
fun of her
you know what made fun of her they
tweeted hey racism is not side effect of
our drug or whatever and it's like dude
you that is the most fucked-up [ __ ] I
can think of but it's you know it's just
you know I think you know I don't know
it's just all right next question
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I always but I could feel it
you know when I'm on stage
cuz always with my stuff because my
stuff is very much trained of me and
Chris Rock said that like my style is
like this you know that's why I have my
podcast random rants which is just me
going like this I don't know where the
[ __ ] I'm gonna go but I always feel like
when you go to the edge and I always
pull back
you don't even just do that you just
know that I'm just getting is closing in
on you you feel like the edge is closing
in on you
a little bit but I've never been that
guy you know anything I've never been
that comic that's gone over here I mean
yeah I'm not like that dirty like Dice
Clay was always that he was pretty crazy
he was pretty gnarly when you know when
he hit so I was never that was never my
style my style was always kind of like
to the edge but never cuz I'm not that
guy that's not who I am you know but I
like to go to the edge it's fun yeah you
walk that line but when you're thinking
of that are you thinking of polish or
the brand or are you thinking of just
your personal feeling no my feeling is a
performer you only main as a performer
you know that's just kind of like where
I go you know right yeah but it's you
know it is what it is what are you gonna
do right you gotta be who you are
ya know sensitive ass [ __ ] on his
channel that's why I got banned you
really did I mean I think we got
demonetised but yes same show
[Music]
[Music]